primero de octubre de 1977 Nueva York
despide al mejor jugador de su época un
partido entre el cosmos y el Santos
sería el colofón de la exitosa carrera
futbolística de Pelé sin embargo su
imagen en los años venideros
sobrepasaría su legado en las canchas
retirada como jugador Pelé fue actor y
cantante en 1980 junto a la también
leyenda del fútbol inglés Bobby Moore y
al reconocido actor Sylvester Stallone
participó en la película Escape a la
victoria un drama bélico ambientado en
la Segunda Guerra Mundial también
participó en la película familiar 11 + 1
pero su verdadera pasión siempre fue la
música en la década de los 60 fue
coestor e intérprete de canciones con la
famosa artista de música popular
brasileña elise Regina además entre 2004
y 2006 fue cantante compositor y
productor ejecutivo del álbum yinya un
talento que explotó desde joven como lo
demuestra en esta entrevista de 1968
[Música]
en el ámbito diplomático fue nombrado
ciudadano del mundo por la ONU en 1977
embajador para la ecología y el medio
ambiente 1992 y embajador de la UNESCO
en 1994
incursionó en la vida política y fue
ministro extraordinario de deportes de
Brasil entre 1994 y 1998 durante esta
época estrechó Los lazos entre
Washington y Brasilia
esta oportunidad
quiero aprovechar esta oportunidad para
pedirle al presidente del país más rico
del mundo que incentive proyectos como
este
porque solo así podemos cambiar el mundo
y acabar con tanta pobreza y falta de
humanidad
legendario dentro del campo y alejado de
los problemas mediáticos tras su retiro
Edson Dante de nacimiento será recordado
por Brasil y el mundo del fútbol
[Aplausos]